Okay Michael, so what I have here on
the screen is two formulas that tell you
how to compute the probability that
a particular action a is the optimal one
given some evidence which
I'm calling the d sub a.
That is the, d is the data set of labels
a number of times you said yes or
no for a b in the optimal action in
both the general case where there can
be any number of policies
that are optimal,
that is any number of actions in
a particular state that could be optimal
versus the case where there can be
only one, the Highlander case, okay?
So I'm just going to kind of read this
out to you and you can just ask as many
questions as you want but
we'll sort of see where it goes.
So, we should read the first
equation in the following way.
So all of these are for a particular
state and you just can apply this in
a given state because we're living in
Markov decision process and then we'd
have to worry about all the other states
where by the state we happen to be.
This is the probability for a given
state, action a is the optimal and
given a sequence of labels that say, yes
this is optimal, no this is not optimal
is equal to this quantity C is just
the probability, the human is correct,
which was 0.8 in our last quiz and
was one in the quiz before that.
Raised to the power delta sub a.
Now what is delta sub a?
Well, delta is just the difference
between the number of times you said
yes, and the number of times
you said no to action a.
Now what does that really mean?
Well remember as you said, when you
were kind of thinking this out loud for
the first one, that what we really
got is multinomials and binomials.
A binomial is a special
case of multinomial.
So what we really has is multinomials.
What we're really doing
is flipping coins.
So every time you sort of flip a coin,
you're getting some evidence of whether
the coin comes up heads or
tails more often.
And so what you have here is
delta basically is a sufficient
statistic that summarizes
the entire sequence that you get.
Now what this means in practice,
is that every time I say yes and no,
it's as if they cancel each other out.
They drag me back towards
the uniform distribution, or
whatever your prior happens to be.
Now a lot of people find it difficult
to wrap their heads around.
It feels like if I flip a coin twice and
it comes up heads once and
tails once,
that's evidence that it's a half.
But if I flip a coin 1000 times and
500 times it says yes and 500 times it
says no, that's somehow more evidence
that it's a half and that's true but
actually in both cases, the maximum
likelihood answer is still one half.
It's just in the second case,
you're even more confident about it and
what we're doing here is we're measuring
basically the mean, not the variance.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
I think so.
Right.
So, in some sense,
it's not telling us how
sure we are of the answer.
It's really just saying what the answer
is that best guesses the answer.
>> Exactly right and and
what this delta kind of summarizes for
you is the only thing that matters is
how many times you said yes versus how
many times you said no, not how
many times you said yes on its own.
So, in the general case,
what we're really saying here is
something kind of neat which is that we
can we can treat every single
action as if they're independent.
And so the probability that a is optimal
depends only upon what you told me
about a,
it doesn't depend upon anything else.
Because as we did in the first example,
if you tell me that
the first action is optimal but
all of them could be optimal.
There's multiple optimal policies, then
the fact you told me something about
that action doesn't actually tell me
anything about any other actions.
And so what we have here is,
basically the probability that I
would see that many times you said
yes normalized by the probability I
would see that many times that you would
say yes versus I would have said all
those times and been wrong about it.
So C to the delta a is a sort of under
the assumption that you are correct.
And 1 minus c is under
the assumption you are not correct.
And that just falls out of
the binomial distribution.
And if we plug in our original answers,
you would see that you end up with
the same thing that we got before and
the special case where
you've only seen one label.
You with me?
>> Yeah, that's cool, yeah I think so.
So, because it's the binomial case,
one per action,
we're not looking at any other actions.
So the denominator there
comes from essentially,
the count of how likely it is that we'd
have those, that number that delta
number versus that if we were wrong,
we would have that delta number the 1-C.
So yeah, I think that feels right to me.